out of the bunker
[Applause]
forced to face the fury
these the pm's darkest days
trying to navigate a route through the
crisis heading to parliament to face
angry mps hopes boris johnson might have
had on call in time on the party's
scandal now long gone there's no
escaping it he's facing the biggest test
of his premiership yet and a packed
chamber marks the gravity of that moment
mr speaker i want to apologize
i know that millions of people
across this country have made
extraordinary sacrifices
over the last 18 months
and i know the rage
they feel
with me
[Music]
and with the government i lead
when they think that in dining street
itself
the rules are not being properly
followed an apology of sorts but look at
the opposition front bench the labour
leader incredulous kierstarm is saying
oh my god the pm sorry that the garden
gathering upset people but still saying
it didn't break lockdown rules when i
went into that garden just after six on
the 20th of may
2020
to thank groups of staff before going
back into my office 25 minutes later to
continue working i believed implicitly
that this was
a work event with hindsight
i should have sent
everyone back inside
i should have found some other way
to thank them
and i should have recognized that
even if it could be said technically to
full
within the guidance
there would be millions and millions of
people
who simply would not see it that way
an explanation provoking fury the labour
leader going in for the kill
after months of deceit and deception
the pathetic spectacle of a man who's
run out of road
his defense his defense that he didn't
realize he was at a party
[Laughter]
it is so ridiculous
he's finally been forced to admit what
everyone knew that when the whole
country was locked down he was hosting
boozy parties in downing street
is he now going to do the decent thing
and resign
words that pain him as his allies look
on worried pensive on the edge of their
seats i regret the way uh the event i
have described uh was handled i bitterly
uh regret it and wish that we could have
done things differently and i have uh
and will continue to apologize for what
we did but mr speaker he must wait uh
for the uh inquiry which will report as
soon as possible this just isn't working
prime minister no everyone could see
what happened exactly it started with
reports of boozy parties in downing
street during lockdown
the prime minister pretended that he had
been assured there were no parties
then the video landed so then he
pretended he pretended he was sickened
and furious
about the parties
now it turns out he was at the parties
all along
can't the prime minister see why the
british public think he's lying through
his teeth the calls for his resignation
relentless this weak and contentious
prime minister can no longer limp on the
message from the public is clear remove
this unfit prime minister from office
and do it now will the prime minister
for the good of the country
except that the party is over and decide
to resign we have seen standards and
public life trashed
so for once can the prime minister do
the honorable thing and resign
a moment of reckoning made worse as his
own side starts to turn on him too he
said with hindsight he would have done
things differently
which for me is uh an acceptance from
the prime minister that it was wrong and
therefore
i don't want to be in this position but
i am in the position now where i don't
think he can continue as leader of the
conservatives
but the row over number 10 parties is
about far more than just politics it's
about people's lives their sacrifices
and their personal loss
one of these stories touched on by the
labour leader today hannah brady's
father sean was just 55 when he lost his
life to covert he was a fit and healthy
key worker she realizes that the prime
minister had parted
in that same garden the very day her
dad's death certificate was signed i
sympathized
deeply with uh with hannah but the pm
sympathy and apology nowhere near enough
for hannah who watched her father sean
pass away in icu just four days before
the may 20th down in street gathering
when i met boris on the 28th of
september 21 in the downing street
garden the same garden that that party
happened in i told him exactly what had
happened to my dad and i showed him a
photo of dad and a ventilator he
attempted to assure me that he'd done
everything he could to protect my dad
that he'd followed the science and that
he'd followed the rules
um it seems almost cruel now that he
hosted five members of bereaved families
listen to their stories of how loved
ones died from kobed in exactly the same
garden where on the 20th of may
he'd invited over 100 people to a party
have you been convinced by his apology
then today not at all no
um
he
reminds me of one of my people so i'm a
trainee teacher that's been caught doing
something that they shouldn't the prime
minister today said sorry but not for
the actual bring your own booze garden
gathering in number 10 rather for the
impression it left in the minds of
voters who at the time were observing
lock down rules a qualified apology then
that left hannah and many of his own mps
deeply unconvinced but it did at least
buy him some time as we await now the
outcome of that independent
investigation about what went on in
number 10 but even if he does survive
that allies admit it's going to get very
very messy
but beyond all the drama in this place
is now a bigger question
is this a pm who has the moral and
political authority to lead this country
once the parties are put to bed
beth rigby sky news westminster